Suppose I have a fair coin which
I toss multiple times.
I want to model a situation
where the results of previous
flips do not affect my beliefs
about the likelihood of heads
in the next flip.
And I would like to describe
this situation by saying that
the coin tosses are
independent.
You may say, we already
defined the notion of
independent events.
Doesn't this notion apply?
Well not quite.
We defined independence
of two events.
But here, we want to talk
about independence of a
collection of events.
For example, we would like to
say that the events, heads in
the first toss, heads in the
second toss, heads in the
third toss, and so on,
are all independent.
What is the right definition?
Let us start with intuition.
We will say that a family of
events are independent if
knowledge about some of the
events doesn't change my
beliefs, my probability model,
for the remaining events.
For example, if I want to say
that events A1, A2 and so on
are independent, I would like
relations such as the
following to be true.
The probability that event A3
happened and A4 does not
happen remains the same even
if I condition on some
information about some
other events.
Let's say if I tell you that
A1 happens or that both A2
happened and A5 did
not happen.
The important thing to notice
here is that the indices
involved in the event of
interest are distinct from the
indices associated with the
events on which I'm given some
information.
I'm given some information about
the events A1, A2, and
A5, what happened to them.
And this information does not
affect my beliefs about
something that has to do
with events A3 and A4.
I would like all relations
of this kind to be true.
This could be one possible
definition, just saying that
the family of events are
independent if and only if any
relation of this type is true.
But such a definition would not
be aesthetically pleasing.
Instead, we introduce the
following definition, which
mimics or parallels our
earlier definition of
independence of two events.
We will say that a collection
of events are independent if
you can calculate probabilities
of intersections
of these events by multiplying
individual probabilities.
And this should be possible
for all choices of indices
involved and for any number
or events involved.
Let us translate this into
something concrete.
Consider the case of three
events, A1, A2, and A3.
Our definition requires that
we can calculate the
probability of the intersection
of two events by
multiplying individual
probabilities.
And we would like all of these
three relations to be true,
because this property should
be true for any
choice of the indices.
What do we have here?
This relation tells us that
A1 and A2 are independent.
A1 and A3 are independent.
This relation tells us that
A2 and A3 are independent.
We call this situation pairwise
independence.
But the definition requires
something more.
It requires that the probability
of three-way
intersections can also be
calculated the same way by
multiplying individual
probabilities.
And this additional condition
does make a difference, as
we're going to see in
a later example.
Is this the right definition?
Yes.
One can prove formally that
if the conditions in this
definition are satisfied,
then any formula of
this kind is true.
In particular, we also have
relations such as the following.
The probability of event A3 is
the same as the probability of
event A3, given that
A1 and A2 occurred.
Or the probability of
A3, given that A1
occurred but A2 didn't.
Or we can continue this
similarly, the probability of
A3 given that A1 did
not occur, and A2
occurred, and so on.
So any kind of information that
I might give you about
events A1 and A2--
which one of them occurred
and which one didn't--
is not going to affect my
beliefs about the event A3.
The conditional probabilities
are going to be the same as
the unconditional
probabilities.
I told you that this definition
implies that all
relations of this kind [are]
true.
This can be proved.
The proof is a bit tedious.
And we will not go through it.